the last thing she said was from  somebody she can't control yeah that is  your problem no whose actions I can't  control which means  and I do and that's why I said I would  rather be in a situation where I can  control myself and not have to be  oriented why wouldn't you just not have  if you want to make life about you and  what you want don't have kids but it's  not about me and what I want I know  that's what I'm saying it is another  wait okay if you if you're putting your  feelings above the kid so if you're  saying you know because I don't want to  get along with a man that I can't  control his actions your words your  words okay so so because you're putting  your feelings above what's best for a  child so if that's what you want to do  then why would you have a child